[Música]
en 1994 yo tenía 25 años tenía ya cuatro
años de ejercer el periodismo y además
yo cubría las fuentes económicas cubría
bancos uno de los bancos que cubría ese
año entre una crisis muy importante de
hecho cerró por ley porque era un banco
público cuando la situación financiera
del banco empezó a complicarse y a mí me
tocaba atender todo lo que estaba
pasando con ese banco yo realmente
trabajé muy duro cuando la situación se
fue volviendo más complicada en el
periódico en el cual yo trabajaba
decidieron que iban a involucrar a más
colegas de la sala de redacción en ese
periódico
pues debo decirles que la primera
reacción mía fue mucha resistencia a
pesar de que eran mis compañeros esa era
mi fuente
yo era mi tema era lo que yo iba a
publicar al día siguiente en el
periódico pues fue muy difícil para mí
en ese momento ceder el tema pero bueno
empezamos a trabajar varios periodistas
en toda la cobertura
les voy a contar una una cosa que ocurre
en periodismo o que por lo menos
nosotros le poníamos le dábamos un
término era hacer fijos un fijo es ir y
pararse durante horas afuera de la
oficina de un funcionario o afuera de la
casa a esperar que aparezca para hacerle
las consultas esto es un fijo yo empecé
a hacer fijos en varios lugares uno de
los cuales era la casa de los hermanos
lópez que eran unos empresarios que
estaban involucrados con ese banco en
negocios una vez ellos salieron en el
carro estábamos varios colegas afuera de
la casa de ellos
salimos corriendo detrás del carro
camarógrafos fotógrafos periodistas
todos corríamos para tratar de obtener
la declaración de hechos eso es más o
menos como cuando ustedes ven los a los
periodistas más o menos pero viendo cómo
hacen para meter el micrófono papá
codazo aquí codazo acá eso ocurre porque
en periodismo tenemos una dinámica muy
fuerte para obtener primicias y
exclusivas esa adrenalina que nos mueve
muy fuerte para eso yo también hoy la
denominó un poco de ego tenemos un poco
de eso cuando hacemos las cosas
en 2016 si ustedes saben que hubo una
revelación de información muy importante
que se conoció como los para matthei
pérez fueron 11 millones de documentos
digitales a mí me gusta esta fotografía
esta que ustedes están viendo porque yo
me imagino 11 millones de papeles y
entonces veo esto y veo muchas salas de
papeles imagínense lo que podía hacer
procesar esa cantidad de información
esa información le llegó a estos dos
periodistas que son dos pero estos
alemanes que trabajan en un medio alemán
muy reconocido en alemania y en otras
partes del mundo
ustedes saben qué pasó saben la historia
yo les pregunto qué hubiera pasado si
estos dos periodistas deciden dejarse
ellos los 11 millones de documentos para
ellos procesarlos solos
posiblemente no hubieran podido los dos
tal vez les hubieran asignado más
periodistas del medio pero cuántos
periodistas podía poner ese medio a
trabajar en once millones de papeles o
de pronto hubieran optado por publicar
solamente la información que tenga que
ver con alemania y de pronto algunos
otros países importantes para alemania y
una gran cantidad de información hubiera
quedado sin revisión
pero ellos ya lo sabemos no decidieron
hacer eso ellos buscaron un consorcio
periodístico internacional y ese
consorcio montó toda la información en
una gran base de datos
con mucha seguridad y a esa base de
datos accedieron 370 periodistas en 707
medios en 80 países del mundo y cada uno
cada uno de los periodistas empezó a
buscar información que podía ser más
relevante para las audiencias de su
medio luego se pusieron de acuerdo y
todos publicaron a la vez el impacto que
tuvo esa esa serie de divulgación de
información de forma simultánea en
muchos países del mundo fue muy grande
yo nada más quiero recordar algunas
cosas el primer ministro de islandia en
ese momento tuvo que renunciar porque él
y su esposa habían fundado una de estas
empresas offshore para evadir pago de
impuestos y no lo habían dicho y él
había llegado es el primer ministro de
islandia bajo estas condiciones tuvo que
renunciar
también hubo por ejemplo el actor jackie
chan fue otro de los que salió
involucrado con este tipo de empresas
leonel messi el que era en ese momento
el primer ministro británico david
cameron tuvo que incluso pedir disculpas
públicas porque su papá había creado una
de estas empresas para manejar el
patrimonio de toda la familia
incluyéndolo a él
incluso esto llegó a la realeza de la
hermana del que era rey en españa pilar
de borbón tuvo que también verse
sometida al escrutinio que hubo porque
la publicación también alcanzó a su
situación personal
pero no solo pasó cosas con gente
conocida como estos que les acaba de
mencionar que abrieron 6.500 casos y se
investigó a 6.500 personas y empresas u
organizaciones que evadían impuestos
y esto tuvo un gran impacto
dentro de la investigación por ejemplo
se descubrió que algunas de las empresas
que operaban bajo estos esquemas
offshore y daban fondos para financiar
el terrorismo y hubo cambios importantes
por ejemplo alemania tomó la decisión a
través de una ley de que todos los
ciudadanos tenían que declarar cuando
creaban tienen que declarar cuando crean
una empresa offshore de este tipo alguna
empresa en algún paraíso fiscal en algún
otro lugar que no es alemania este fue
el impacto que tuvo esta divulgación
ahorita estamos con los pandora papers
en pleno proceso también vamos a ver
finalmente qué pasa con el paso del
tiempo
esto que hacemos en periodismo se llama
divulgar hechos de interés público
divulgamos cosas que muchos no quieren
que se conozcan
tenemos que tener entonces una gran
independencia y una gran visión desde
los medios para que esas cosas se
divulgue en la independencia económica
es muy importante no solo se divulgan
cosas que la gente que no quiere por
ejemplo en regímenes totalitarios la
denuncia constante puede hacer producir
cambios cuando hay personas que abusan
del poder en los países eso es lo que
está pasando en nicaragua aquí nomás
aquí en este momento en costa rica hay
50 periodistas nicaragüenses exiliados
trabajando desde aquí con muy pocos
recursos y una buena parte de ellos son
súper jóvenes los he visto sé cómo son
salieron productos de toda la crisis del
2018 muchos de ellos ellos trabajan muy
juntos se apoyan aunque trabajan en
distintos medios colaboran y se dan
también mucho apoyo moral hay otra
organización que se llama voces en
libertad que la lidera y berta valle
berta es periodista y además es esposa
de una de las personas que están en este
momento presa también la fundación
violeta barrios de chamorro que ahora
están en exilio porque fue desconocida y
empezó todo un proceso de investigación
contra ella trabaja en este momento con
20 medios en alianza la voz es de
libertad trabaja con 8 medios en alianza
que trabajan juntos para generar
divulgación de contenidos yo estoy
segura y tengo confianza de que el
trabajo de estos colegas nicaragüenses
va a tener resultados y vamos a poder
ver cambios y nicaragua producto de
gente valiente como ellos que no va a
permitir que este régimen totalitario
siga y a mí eso me da mucha fe mucha
esperanza esos colegas valientes
nicaragüenses y esa gente que hace un
gran trabajo por denunciar y poner
información a todos nosotros sobre
hechos de interés público
este es un caso muy interesante el
femicidio es un problema global esta fue
una publicación o así se vio la
publicación en el periódico el tiempo de
colombia aquí lo que hubo fue que varios
periódicos de distintos países se
pusieron de acuerdo aquí costa rica
también participó y entonces todos
homologaron estadísticas de femicidios
buscaron casos armaron todo un proyecto
y publicaron todos de forma simultánea
este es otro caso este es la forma en
que lo publicó la voz de guanacaste que
es otro medio aquí en costa rica el
fenómeno de la migración es un fenómeno
global y estamos viendo cómo está
ocurriendo una situación muy grave en
américa latina' personas que salen de un
lugar y pasan país por país para tratar
de llegar a ese lugar a donde ellos
aspiran esta publicación de que se
publicó este proyecto que se publicó
sobre emigrantes vean ustedes la
cantidad de organizaciones que
participaron muchos medios pero no sólo
medios participaron otras organizaciones
que tienen intereses en el tema de
inmigración
algunos de ellos pusieron dinero para
todo el proceso en la producción
periodística y algunos tuvieron
participaciones muy diversas
esto es este muchacho que está acá y
espero que me esté viendo es yo johan es
un periodista muy joven él es de la zona
atlántica de costa rica
johan en este momento bueno fue pasante
además nuestro dentro del programa de
periodismo johan con alguna regularidad
sale en este canal de televisión acá en
costa rica contando que está pasando en
la zona caribe sur que es donde él está
específicamente de esta forma nosotros
nos damos cuenta de que está pasando
allá porque era hace todo un esfuerzo
personal muy importante para poner a
disposición del canal y de todos
nosotros ese contenido
a mí el tema de migrantes me interesa a
mí la situación del femicidio y
denunciar lo que ocurre con la muerte
mujeres me interesa a mí me interesa
saber qué pasaba en la zona atlántica
a ustedes les interesa
la información la calidad de la
información nos hace mejores personas
nos hace mejores personas desde que
somos chicos y tenemos información de
calidad hasta que somos adultos por eso
es que es muy importante que haya
información de calidad y periodismo de
calidad cómo hacemos periodismo de
calidad cuando los medios están en medio
de una situación muy compleja porque la
publicidad encontró múltiples formas de
encausarse ya no solo con los medios
donde ellos buscan formas de obtener
ingresos y recursos para seguir
financiando la producción periodística
sobre todo la información periodística
de calidad para lo cual claramente no
sólo se ocupan recursos económicos sino
también visión cómo lo hacemos
mi propuesta y la de muchos es que el
periodismo colaborativo es una forma de
lograr darle recursos a los medios para
que puedan generar periodismo de calidad
una de varias formas hay por lo menos
seis mecanismos o seis formas diversas
de generar estrategias de periodismo
colaborativo
lo cual implica obviamente como vimos en
los casos que les mencioné ponerse de
acuerdo sobre la base de un objetivo
común un propósito común y lo
interesante del periodismo colaborativo
es que no solamente pueden participar
periodistas pueden participar
organizaciones y personas que tienen
interés en que haya ciertos hechos que
se den a conocer
esto se hace entonces trabajando en red
no solo periodistas muchas otras
personas empresas y organizaciones
pueden trabajar para lograr esto
yo quiero creer que esta es una forma de
que en costa rica produzcamos periodismo
de calidad hace 25 años con la historia
que les comencé a contar de este banco y
la cobertura que yo tuve que dar junto
con otros colegas
creo que difícilmente podíamos pensar
que nos podíamos poner de acuerdo
periodistas de distintos medios para
procesar la gran cantidad de información
que era necesaria obtener y revisar de
lo que estaba pasando con este banco
estatal que cerró en 1994 yo hoy me
rehuso a creer 25 años después que
tengamos que seguir dándonos de codazos
yo quiero creer que podemos tener
capacidad de con confianza con reglas
claras con transparencia hacer trabajo
colaborativo quiero creer que eso es una
buena forma de hacer periodismo en costa
rica quiero creer que además es una
buena forma de que todos trabajemos en
muchas de nuestras áreas muchísimas
gracias
[Música]